THE IOST YEAR'S ATTACK ON PI
ITY OF
ONE OF OANHEND THOSE STIGATED I.
UCH FOJO
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO
ABOUREEY RT WITH -
LIES E TACK AND REPUBLICAN
G T  AND
ADERVIVE S HAVE
EA ADERTGREAT DA
TRUTH ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
BECARITICALLY
MAE BELIEVS
THN INAMOUNT  OFS FACE IT,
OF D
E ST YEAR, AND
MAUMING THATSINFORON
TO THINK THAE VIOLENK TH
AT OANUARY W TSTATUES,S INSANE H
URS TO GETTOP TRUM TO DEPLOY TH
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM THE JANUARY
6tMME TOM
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT HPE YOU
PP
I
D FROM THEOMTTU'ADD ROLE THAT DA
TRAPPED IN I THINK THEASEMEN
NDEN
EY WERT OF
CAPITOL PLEADING FI IMMEDIATELY
RIOTLICE TCAPITOD TRYING TO SEN
TH ANDEPT
OF THE ARMY, WRE REPEATENID THE
GUARD.
I CALL T AND ACTIVATED
STAGINE BO ODISTRICT READY TO GE
PRK TWRTHY, CRETARY  ARM
R HELP. SENT THEMN.BELIEVE THE
GUARRST TO ARRIVE CAPITOL.
THE NE STATE POLICE CA
D.C. GUARDTW HHEETROPOLITAN CE
U KNOW ARE IN
THE YEAR THA ABOY IT TOO
I ONE   WNETO THE
TTOM OF.
ULD GIVEHEIT OF
THE TOUT AND ST WAS THE
TIS
THAISOMETHING
REUT AE,TO HAVE
THF THSE
DEFENSE AND WE DT GET IT.>>N .
YOU TESTEDOSE FOCORONAVIRUS JUS
FULLCCINATYOU BOOSTE AIM
PHASE, EVEN PEOPLE WHO DO
EVERYTHING RIGHT, LIKE Y, CAN
T .
WL, YES, AND I LUCKILFULLINED
AND BOOSTED, IT GERECK.OLATE FOR
DIDN GET ANYLSE
S W OMICROW THAT ECTION, I HAD
WHO ARE FULLY PROTTE K YEO
HOSPITAL AND THAT'S THE THING WN
DEATH, AND THEY'RE
BEAUTIUSE NOW, WE HAVE2%E VAAT
THE MOST
HAVE OAN8%F THBE VACCIISSPONSIB.
WE'RE S
GEOSNDIN
ND A
NURSING HOS HEE LS AND OUR
ARE NEARLY TWO YEARS
IT'S LIKE DE WE'RE
KN WHAT WE HAD AT THE>> THERE AH
COVID PATIENTS HOSPILILAND
HOSPITAL ASSOCIA TT L FACILITIEE
G CAPACIU JUSTDED  THAT.E  TEPW
IRS,D THE , EAKING OF,HELP?
, SOE'VE BEEN TALKTH PY A
DOCTORHAT DON'T LY, THESE HEROEL
WORKING SOYEARS, THERE'S FATIGUG
HLS THAT ARNG
DOWN AND BEINGECTED, SO
WE'RE TA AF AC
WE ALREADY PUT $10ING INTO
E SPITALS AND NURSE IV ROUOF
AL GNUEADA OF OU CANUT
CAHET  EVETH A
UGTH.
LONEURS E  P
THIS IT'
TO BE THE
WOT THE YE
G E
ACTION WSSIBLY CAN TO HELPAND
NCE NCTW
AN, YOU
PREVENT HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
GOVER BYOU
GO, I HAVE TO ASK ABOUINGTON PO"
INVESTIGATION ATTHIS WEEK ABOUT
EMOY MARYLPANDEMIC RESPONSE, COT
S.
A UI
OFFICOUNCAN YOARANTE
>>.H WAS IN OSMESS?
K,RE
OUSLY.
IT'S SOMETHING WD ONE ENTI ST IN
WASHON" WE EVER HAVE COMM
RN DOCENG IN THE PERYES.PRESERVE
NOTO TH
WE PRERV A
WE RESPOND THUNDRE
UT OUT NEARLY 1 MILLION PAGES  E
BUER
NOIM A